even the military has gone woke you saw
this during the Biden Administration you
even saw this under Trump the military
pushing back General milley talking
about white rage remember that the Joint
Chiefs of Staff talking about how how
our servicemen need to focus on the real
issues like white privilege and white
rage and then during covid what happened
our military forced a vaccine mandate on
our service men and women these the
people who are sacrificing their lives
who are who are putting it on the line
for us to protect our country these are
very very healthy young people generally
speaking who faced very little risk from
the Coronavirus
they were told no you have to take the
jab one jab two jab however many Jabs
you can take the jab that like all Jabs
has medical risks and according to
reports would appear to have resulted
in a lot of vaccine injuries well one
such person who is claiming a vaccine
injury is Carolina stancek 23 year old
service member in the National Guard
after getting the primary series of
moderna Carolina suffered heart attacks
a mini stroke asthma the list goes on
Carolina thank you for coming on the
show
thank you Michael I appreciate it so one
thank you for your service two thank you
for helping to expose what seems to me
at best rank incompetence at worst real
corruption in the way that our military
is run what happened to you
um before I start I have to disclaim
that everything that I speak on opinions
thoughts and experiences are my own not
representing the deity or the uh US Army
right what happened to me got the
vaccine was told that you know in order
to stay in the service you had to get
this vaccine uh get it before you are
going to be on active duty uh otherwise
you're not going to recover and so got
it early while I was Drilling and
now and two years later not recovering
what what were the injuries what was the
timetable there are going to be some
people who are skeptical they'll say
what the Liberals say which is oh
actually you just had an injury from the
virus not from the vaccine or they they
might say well it's just a coincidence
and there's no data to suggest that this
was from the vaccine so what's your take
right
uh I was working in the ER at the time
and so I got tested all the time for
covid never had a positive test come
back I got tested in the military never
got a positive test back but when I did
get the vaccine I experienced things
like fevers which I'd never experienced
in my life
um it was my first fever I had numbness
uh pressure in my chest asthmatic
complications dizziness a high heart
rate things like that and I didn't
really know what was going on but I knew
that it was weird I was a healthy
individual and so I still don't know
what I was thinking when those things
were happening I was told that it was
maybe common maybe just a weird side
effect of the vaccine
how long did those symptoms persist
because a lot of the vaccine Peddlers
will say well you'll have a couple of
days of discomfort but then it'll all go
away
uh I got it shortly after the first one
within first 24 hours the second one
they had gotten worse and that's when
the fever started
um so that's about a month apart and
then 10 weeks later diagnosed with
asthma
um so that's 10 weeks in and October
2021 so this is about uh six months
later I had my first heart attack
and just since then it's been going on
what did the doctors tell you after the
heart attack
they were very nonchalant about it
um they didn't seem all that surprised
they didn't think anything of it it
wasn't like oh you're only 21 what's
going on
um I was given drugs uh made me pretty
loopy and then sent to bed rest and I I
just remember like they gave me a lot of
pain medications things like that
do you have a history of heart attack in
your family is there is there any other
explanation that you can think of other
than these shots
100 no never been to the hospital a day
in my life I've been nine times since
then so Carolina you you have your
first heart attack
the doctors don't seem particularly
impressed by it
is this
is that because they've seen other
people with these kinds of injuries from
the vaccines I don't want you to put
words in anybody's mouth but it just is
bizarre to me that a doctor could see a
healthy 21 year old have a heart attack
and sort of shrug it off
um a lot of it was have you ever had any
of this go on before in your life have
you ever had chest pains have you ever
had loss of feeling in your body uh
stabbing pains and I was like no I've
never experienced this they were like
did you ever have any tachycardia which
is high heart rate issues and like and I
was like no I'm an athlete
um we're typically the ones with lower
heart rates and so I they didn't seem
all that phased by it but a lot of
people after I had that first heart
attack doctors people who took my blood
work people who ran my EKGs they were
like how old are you and I was like 21
22 depending on when I was in the ER and
they started saying you know hey we've
been seeing an increase of people but
we're not really supposed to talk about
it
um I had been told by military uh
doctors well civilian DOD doctors they
had said yeah we see a lot of cases of
this heart complications asthmatic
complications things like that but we're
not really supposed to talk about it and
so that was a big frustration
so you hear this from the doctors
presumably there's some follow-up with
your superiors in the military chain of
command if a 21 year old has a heart
attack that's that's going to come up
what did they tell you
um chain of command didn't really say
all that much but I got recommended for
medical retirement and I'm still in and
they just started this past weekend my
medical retirement so
if you do the math I think that's about
a year and a half later
in the meantime that first heart attack
was not the only issue that you dealt
with no I was dealing with a loss of
feeling in my body uh I guess they they
called it neuropathy and we didn't
really know where that was coming from
um I was experiencing blacking out every
time I would stand up or sit up a simple
task like putting on my boots to wear my
uniform I couldn't do that without
getting tired so it used to take me on
like average 20 minutes to put boots on
this this was your career I mean you
this was this was a job that you were
doing this was service now that's been
taken away from you
what are you going to do now
um I moved to Florida I wanted to go
into anti-human trafficking once all
this stuff came up
um I was like well I need to be a voice
for someone who can't speak for
themselves that's pretty much what I
wanted to do I wanted to fight for
people and make sure that Justice was
being served somewhere
um obviously that's not through the
military anymore and so I moved to
Florida in hopes to do that elsewhere
and
this has become my life now
have other service members come to you
especially since yeah you haven't been
on all that many shows yet I'm sure that
you're getting requests and we'll be
getting many more requests to tell your
story have other people hearing this
reached out and said hey something
similar happened to me
a lot of people have um I've had people
from Poland uh Canada
Guatemala like all over the world have
reached out and said they've seen some
of my interviews someone had posted a
emerald Robinson interview and it went
viral on Tick Tock and Tick Tock took it
down
and Tick Tock took it down wow so I
reposted it I made a tick tock to repost
it chairman she will not get that past
you that's that's an incredible
incredible story it's a credible story
because we've we've heard similar things
from from around the branches of service
now that you've been pushed into medical
retirement
has anyone apologized as anyone who is
pushing you into this said hey sorry we
made you take this shot
I haven't gotten any apologies but I got
a lot of looks funny looks I guess you
could say and they were like well how
old are you and I said you know I'm 20
well now 23 and these are things that
have been going on since I was 21 and a
major in the military she looked at me
she was like this is insane are you one
of those cases
and I said yeah and so I got my first
exemption from any further vaccinations
and so now I'm speaking out on how to
get those exemptions for other service
members
this is the part that a lot of people
don't talk about which is
everybody knows everybody knows that
something is up and what we were told
about the Total Safety and total
efficacy of these vaccines obviously
didn't come true because they kept
changing their story on safety and the
advocacy including Rachelle valenski
including Dr fauci including Joe Biden
and everybody knows it feels almost like
the stories you would hear about the
Soviet Union where everybody knows
something but you're not allowed to say
it even though you know that the other
guy knows you all have to just keep
pretending you all have to keep living
in a lie where everything's hunky-dory
yeah
that's exactly right really really tough
case thank you for speaking out and for
your service and for
at least shedding some light so that
some good can come from this before we
go
see if there are any questions uh from
the audience no it's mostly people just
screaming in their text screaming in
indignation and capital letters and uh
exclamation marks one question before we
go from rahey the Ambassador Carolina
will you consider suing the military
um I I've considered it I have about a
year before I can't use some of the
documents that I have
um there was a specific phone call that
I do want to use
as evidence
that if I can use that that would be
great that was through military base and
so I called one of the case managers and
it's like the first time I really talked
about it but um lies were made about me
and I was denied Cardiology appointments
after my second heart attack and between
the first and the second one that's two
months and I had still yet to see a
cardiologist and they had been denying
me medical care for over four months can
I ask what the lies were
so they told the doctor that I was
unable to make it to Fort Bliss Texas I
was stationed in Arizona I was unable to
make it to Fort Bliss Texas because I
was out of state with a family emergency
with my father first of all I was in the
state second of all I don't have a dad
and third of all I was able to make it
and I needed that appointment I was two
days after a heart attack
and so after that inconvenient first
heart attack
you are denied
Heart Care Cardiology care
on this bogus law obviously demonstrable
lie and then you have another heart
attack
that's as scandalous As It Gets
yeah and I got
am I allowed to curse on the show you
can do whatever you want on the show
okay so I got told when I had asked them
why is my appointment appointment
canceled I had found out through my
platoon that it was canceled they didn't
tell me and it was 12 hours before the
appointment and so I found out through
my Bluetooth that's a HIPAA violation
opening up about medical information
about others without consent
um so that was a big issue and when I
found out went down to the drill
Sergeant's office and I spoke to them
and I asked them what's going on and me
crying I was like this is insane like
you guys can't just sit here and tell me
that's canceled it's been in the books
for months now and you guys are the ones
who scheduled it
and so I walked away and I was like I'm
tired of this place I want my medical
records and they told me to quit
quit thinking about your heart attack
that you had and the and the hard
appointment that was canceled
basically so I made those calls and
found that yeah I made those calls and
that's how I found out that recording of
the phone call through the appointment
line and the case manager at the other
base and so I asked her how long do I
have until I can use this and she said
it'll be
um unable to be used in two years and so
I said okay
be expecting a call back and I got her
name and her phone number
wow
conservative student asks which vaccine
did you get
was my daughter yeah
yeah cater Gator says do you work with
other skeptical people other people who
worked uh with me in a pharmaceutical
research laboratory were also skeptical
of the vaccine as it was first being
released so before you got it were you
skeptical of of taking the shot
yeah so I was in National Intelligence
and Homeland Security for school and so
we had to do a lot of case studies on
covet itself and a lot of the
correlations had to do with Anthrax
um we found a lot of ties to Anthrax in
our studies and I was like well this is
not a virus that we expect it's not
really what people think it is and
there's a lot more to it than simply
saying it's kind of like the flu or it's
a really bad cold you know people are
just dying
um there's a lot more to it well you saw
of course when when the crazy conspiracy
theorists said at the outset of covid
that it probably didn't come from a bad
batch of bat soup at the Wuhan wet
Market might have something to do with
the bio lab that was just down the
street being funded in part by the US
government
and people said oh you that's crazy
that's a conspiracy theory Factory all
the rest and then now they've all
essentially admitted that it very likely
in all likelihood the virus came from
that laboratory what else do we not know
what else were we told was a crazy
conspiracy theory Heather mama says we
really appreciate you coming forward
Carolina
we do thank you very much wishing you
all of the best of luck and and please
keep us posted as as you pursue this
further because I hope I hope you get
some justice for for what was done to
you
yeah thank you if you want to support
Carolina because her medical care is not
being paid for right now by the military
or really anybody else other than you
head on over to givecento.com Carolina
k-a-r-o-l-i-n-a
[Music]